password 8 charactersDo you feel like it's good to be like forthright about
what you're looking for?
Absolutely.
Why waste your time with this?
Like well maybe like he'll change or it'll work.
Yeah.
Cause if he's a Scorpio and you don't want a Scorpio,
it's like why waste your time get a Libra like,
oh my God.
Libras are,
I mean at Capricorns are fine too.
Okay,
wait.
Oh,
here we go.
Hey photo bomber.
No good
writing.
You guys.
This is my makeup from yesterday.
We'll just do it.
Okay,
cool.
Well how are you guys
Redo?
All right.
Anyone who doesn't want to go on a date with Angie?
Three two,
one.
Wait,
but I can't text this fast.
So slow down.
Like if you're a Scorpio,
I'm not even into astrology either.
All I know is that they're really
mean.
Oh
sure.
I definitely do need a date.
Somebody who's like down for Vegan food once in a while all the time.
Mostly Vegan.
Possible.
I like everyone's Downey Vegan food.
Penny one's not down to eat vegan food.
Three,
two,
one.
Skirt.
Donuts are Vegan too.
I mean,
I really do appreciate adventurous sex just cause I'm an obviously an
adventurous person.
If someone's down to have sex in the park,
I'm like all about it.
Or,
or nine apart.
Cause there's kids.
Hmm.
Do we have swipe on our phones?
Is that how we're doing?
It's so fast.
Yeah.
It's your thumbs.
Okay.
You can stay.
Really?
Everyone's down.
I'm,
I'm wait.
Thanks for your honesty.
Ooh.
Yeah.
You know,
I really do love Brown eyes.
Like I'm going to start there.
We'll say brown hair,
black hair.
So they have to have brown or black hair.
Oh,
okay.
Wow.
This counts.
That's something
I think so.
All right.
Are we on in here about Brown eyes and Brown hair and black hair counts,
right?
Oh yeah,
sorry.
Yeah,
and they both Brown eyes black and
I have one.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'd prefer somebody.
Ooh,
it's not religious.
Yeah.
No.
Okay.
I'm down for like,
you know when we're like senior citizens to get,
be like domestic partners.
That's the legal term.
But other than that,
no.
No marriage,
no kids.
Honestly,
no cats either.
But,
oh,
I do want a house with a backyard to grow some strawberries.
That's all.
Hmm.
Roll away.
Hey,
yeah,
those were all my questions.
That's that.
Let's go have sex on the beach now.
Nothing.
I mean,
that's what's really weird.
It was interesting.
We're in 2018 it feels like we're definitely like going places.
I just think like,
I know what I want and if somebody knows that they want,
why not say it to manifest it?
You know,
like people have said it straight to my face before and like,
that feels right.
I don't know.
Like you're too young and it's like,
okay,
cool.
I have no control over that.
Or like you smoke too much weed.
It's like,
well,
I have control over that,
but fuck you.
I'm not going to change.
So
why waste time?
You know,
I do.
Are we in exchange that?
Yeah,
let's do that.
Okay.
My neighbor,
I know,
dude.
No,
I feel like now we're going to run into each other there.
Um,
can I type it because I don't know.